معنا في المتابعه من خان يونس مراسل
الجزيره مؤمن الشرافي اهلا بك مؤمن نتابع
معك بطبيعه الحال الاثار للقصف الاسرائيلي
التي الذي طالع عدد من المناطق منها مخيم
المغازي والبريج
ايضا نعم عبد السلام جثامين الشهداء
نستطيع ان نقول انها تتكدس في ساحه مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح بعد سلسله من
الغ الغارات الجويه عشرات الغارات الجويه
التي نفذتها طائرات جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على مخيمي المغازي وايضا
البريج بالاضافه الى الاطراف الشرقيه من
مخيم النصيرات وسط القطاع الطواقم الطبيه
وايضا طواقم الدفاع المدني تقول ان هناك
اعدادا كبيره من المفقودين والشهداء بين
ركام المنازل التي تعرضت
للقصف الاسرائيلي بعشرات الصواريخ في مخيم
المغازي وايضا القصف المدفعي والغارات
الجويه التي استهدفت بالتوازي مخيم البريج
ما دفع اعداد كبيره من سكان هذا المخيم
الى ترك منازلهم والنزوح الى مراكز
الايواء التابعه للنور في المخيم للاحتماء
بها مع تواصل القصف والغارات الجويه
الاسرائيليه نتحدث عن اكثر من
150,000 نسمه يعيشون داخل مخيم
البريج بينهم اعداد كبيره من النازحين
الذين اجبرتهم قوات الاحتلال على النزوح
من المنطقه الشماليه و مدينه غزه الى
منطقه جنوب الوادي بداعي انها منطقه امنه
ولكن الصواريخ والقذائف الاسرائيليه
تلاحقهم هناك اعداد كبيره من بين الشهداء
هم من النازحين الذين لجوا الى هذه
المناطق التي تتعرض للقصف حتى هذه اللحظه
قبل قليل سمع دوي انفجار يبدو انه ناج عن
غاره اسرائيليه على مخيم النصيرات وسط
القطاع ايضا الغارات الاسرائيليه بعد
المجزره التي ارتكبت في مخيم المغازي
والتي تقدر المصادر الطبيه ان يكون العدد
مرشح للزياده الى اكثر من 70 شهيدا
الغارات استهدفت طرقا رئيسيه واصله بين
مخيمات البريج والمغازي وايضا النصيرات
ايضا الاوضاع الانسانيه صعبه في هذه
المنطقه مع عدم توفر المواد الاساسيه من
الغذاء والدواء وايضا مع قرب نفاذ المياه
الصالحه للشرب في تلك المناطق التي تتعرض
للقصف الاسرائيلي والتي قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي انها منطقه عمليات عسكريه كما
يدعي ايضا هنا في شرق مدينه خان يونس قصفت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه منزلا شرق
المدينه اصفر حتى هذه اللحظه عن استشهاد
11 فلسطينيا بين بينهم اطفال
ونساء وتقول المصادر الطبيه وطواقم الهلال
الاحمر ان هناك اعداد كبيره من المفقودين
بين هذا بين ركام هذا المنزل الذي دمر على
رؤوس ساكنيه بالتوازي تتواصل الغارات
الاسرائيليه ايضا والقصف المدفعي في شرق
دير البلح وايضا شرق مخيم المغازي وشرق
مخيم البريج بالاضافه الى اطلاق نار من
الزوارق الحربيه الاسرائيليه على السواحل
الغربيه على الساحل الغربي لمدينه خان
يونس وايضا المنطقه الوسطى الى جانب مدينه
رفح جنوبي القطاع الاوضاع صعبه جدا وزاره
الصحه تقول ان اكثر من مليون ونصف نازح في
المنطقه الجنوبيه التي يدعي جيش الاحتلال
انها امنه والتي كثف غاراته الجويه
واستهدافه في هذه المنطقه خلال الايام
الماضيه واختتمت واختمها واختتمها مساء
امس بمجزره ارتكبها داخل مخيم المغ غازي
بقصف عدد من المنازل على رؤوس ساكنيها وهي
منازل بسيطه
للاجئين الفلسطينيين تقول وزاره الصحه ان
900000 نازح من اكثر من بين 100 مليون من
بين من بين مليون ونصف نازح هم اي مهددون
بالموت نتيجه عدم
توفر الظروف الصحيه المناسبه لهم وعدم
توفر المواد الاساسيه وعدم توفر الدواء
والغذاء والماء وايضا التطعيمات التي نفذت
منذ ايام للاطفال حديثي الولاده في قطاع
غزه شكرا جزيلا لك مؤمن الشرفي مراسل
الجزيره كان معنا من خان
يونس